[Musique]
l'homme moderne se doit de fustiger avec
véhémence toutes les formes de racisme
après tout les gens de couleurs ne sont
ils pas des gens comme nous comme vous
malheureusement il est extrêmement
difficile de prévoir une émeutes
raciales
c'est pourquoi il vaut mieux attendre
qu'elle émeutes raciales ai commencé
afin de pouvoir la mater grâce à cette
ultime rempart de la civilisation contre
la barbarie que constitue le para bellum
9 mm attention je vais maintenant
déclenché une émeute raciale comment
c'est simple regardez bien eh bien oui
vous avez compris pour bien mater une
émeutes raciales
il faut tirer sur les blancs avec une
balle à blanc et sur les noirs avec une
balle à noir est maman
[Musique]